[Applause]
[Applause]
oh no it happened i jumped too high
welcome to the arena outside of space
and time where we have 2022 tremetrious
drummond
versus 2001 vince half man half amazing
carter
[Applause]
i gotta remember that dunk for next year
wow i gotta say i'm a huge fan let me
guess poster on your wall you both know
why you're here because i'm the most
exciting player in the league
jinx rolls off simple game to 11 win by
two
good job with the acrobatic finish that
ain't nothing
check this out
you know that straight mark infringement
shooting one of the few weak spots in
john's game my turn
only then sanity baby
belt's in the house
oh watch your pockets job with that
written dry mentality
you know not every play has to be in the
top 10.
why not
[Applause]
token knock over a car this is why i
don't do dunk contests
[Applause]
is it traveling do you take four steps
in the air
we want to see more dogs i'm more than
just dunk
this is just playing regular basketball
now
and he misses it at the rim i don't
think you got it
you sure
lucky ass shot
oh
rap
now game point
getting ready for your future as a role
player maybe but today that day
[Music]
oh no it looks like jazz starting to
descend
[Applause]
[Music]
i would have had you if it wasn't for
gravity sure that wasn't just the weight
of expectations you got joy
wow is back and look how improved he is
[Music]
you